Patrick had a vague feeling something  was about to happen something in the  breeze of Twilight and whispered just  going to happen tonight just passing  through we're moving here in town for  esa's house some guys been breaking into  people's homes murdering the parents  sparing the Donald season the house  along with the parents of baldies I like  to write stories incident in a ghost  land is your most personal book so far  your sales are through the roof they  adore you  Oh Vera they never should have stayed in  that house SAT to create your own world  I guess the question is why write this  book but to keep from going insane  keeps reliving the night over and over  let me die alone never stayed in that  house so nobody's here no why is he here  yeah I know what you want from your  sister what did you do to me  [Music]  [Applause]  you